i know there's now one question at the
very top of your minds
and that is how fast and how effectively
we can get
these millions of new vaccines into the
arms of the most vulnerable
and those who need them most and
you want to know that we in government
the nhs the armed forces local and
regional government
government at every level are truly
throwing everything
at it around the clock if necessary and
i believe that with the country once
again in lockdown
and all the difficulties that means for
you for
your family for students for education
uh
for your businesses and
of course with the tragic number of
deaths that we're seeing that we've seen
today
you have a right to understand exactly
how we're cracking this problem and how
the national vaccine effort is
progressing and you rightly want to know
how we're going to reach the target
that i set out earlier this week of
offering a slot
for vaccination by 15th of february
for everyone in those key groups
identified
by the joint committee on vaccination
and immunization
that's over 12 million people in england
and 15 million
in the uk including older care home
staff
eldercare home residents and staff
everyone 70 or over
all frontline nhs and care staff
and all those who are clinically
extremely vulnerable
and just to remind you of the importance
of these groups for fighting the disease
they account
for 88 of all those who have sadly
lost their lives and so our tactics
are first to use the immense natural
capacity of the nhs and
by the end of the week there will be
over 1 000 gp led
sites providing vaccines 223
hospital sites seven giant vaccination
centers
and a first wave of 200 community
pharmacies
if all goes well these together should
have the capacity
to deliver hundreds of thousands of
vaccines per day
by january the 15th and it is our plan
that everyone should have a vaccination
available within a radius of 10 miles
and it follows from that that the limits
will not be on
our distributional power but on the
supply
of vaccines and i have no doubt
that we have enough supply to vaccinate
these four groups
by the february the 15th deadline and we
also have
the distributional network to do it
and to continue an expanding program
down that priority list
yes let's be clear this is a national
challenge on a scale
like nothing we've seen before and it
will require
an unprecedented national effort and of
course
there will be difficulties appointments
will be changed
but as brigadier prosser will shortly
explain
the army is working hand in glove with
the nhs and local councils
to set up our vaccine network and using
battle preparation techniques to help us
keep up the pace
we'll publish our full vaccine
deployment plan
on monday along with daily updates
on the progress we're making we've now
vaccinated 1.26 million people in
england
113 000 in scotland 49 000 in wales
and 46 000 in northern ireland so all
together
nearly 1.5 million people across the uk
have now received their first dose and
within two to three weeks
all of them will have a very
considerable
degree of immunity and it's thanks to
the
arrival of the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine which can be stored at room
temperature
that we can accelerate the pace of
vaccination in care homes
we're using that vaccine in care homes
for the first time
today and by the end of the month we
hope to have offered every elderly
care home resident a vaccine
our new national booking service will
also make it easier
to book and access appointments so i
urge
everyone to come forward because it's
absolutely vital
that we should have confidence in these
vaccines
i want to thank everyone involved in
this extraordinary national effort
all the gps nurses pharmacists all the
staff
behind the scenes our armed forces local
councils
are scientists who've not only developed
the
uh oxford astrological vaccine the first
ever like life-saving
treatment of covid in the form of
dexamethasone
but also i'm pleased to tell you today
uh british scientific research
has now contributed to uh to the
creation of more
new life-saving treatments that have
just passed rigorous
clinical trials in pr in particular uh
tos toscilisu mob
i'll sorry i'll say it again uh
tosilizumab
and sarilumab
though shortly on everybody's lips which
have been found to reduce the risk of
death
for critically ill patients by almost a
quarter
and they've cut time spent in intensive
care
by as much as 10 days and these
life-saving drugs will be available
through the nhs with immediate effect
potentially saving thousands of lives
and
finally again i want to thank you
the british public for coming forward to
be vaccinated in the numbers that you
have
still greater than all the countries of
europe put together
and yes of course we are in a race
against time
but i can assure you that we are doing
everything we can
to vaccinate as many people as possible
across our whole
united kingdom and in the meantime
please
stay at home protect the nhs and save
lives